we're going to have a look at these two
ways of visualizing visualizing what
data looks like we should see lots and
others all I kind of thing and so in
fact you might even like to put a little
of Arab you these are visualizations of
numerical data but we're trying to put
it in a form that makes it easier for us
to know what's going on and
understandeth okay so firstly i'm just
going to really really quickly show you
because it's not that complicated what a
dot plot looks like you seen these
before okay so this is dot [ __ ]
unsurprisingly it's called a dot [ __ ]
because it's for God's right ok now
let's talk about this for a second you
can see if you squint really really high
you've got good vision but on the
horizontal axis down here and if you
want read that very good exercise okay
so we talked about the ages of a bunch
of different people so you can see
arranged down from the youngest person
looks like they're 19 they're 19 years
old and it goes all the way up to 60 and
so far so good I've on the vertical axis
you don't even really need to be able to
read that to know what do you think
that's about that's the number of people
right now what's written there is count
as he had counted how many people aren't
such as such an age okay so let's make a
couple of quick observations when you
look at this right some things are
really obvious they kind of slap you in
the face that are obvious kid but not
obvious if we knew all the numbers right
so for instance here are the things that
we're looking for you can draw this down
with me as well what a dot what's good
for you can visually immediately
see things like the median or the mean
or the mode right what do we call these
we had a beauty important phrase all
these different things we called the
measures odds and other measures of yeah
measures of central tendency as we said
right so you have a look right even if
you don't look precisely you can say
look the middle is clearly around here
you see that degree and you can just
read that down eat a I'm guessing space
/ video it's not precise but it's a
visualization at least at the moment it
doesn't need to be precise you look at
it quickly you get a general sense we
can see the center of the group please
but you can also see remember I saw that
estimated books in ism I sort of
estimated the center of the room was
around Lake codes ok next one that's not
a crazy number but there are other
important things about this different
people that's not just a setup for
example I don't look at these three
peaks here she knows so we call those we
call them costumes these are kind of
like where the ages or the scores or
whatever it is been looking at where
they're bunched up together okay so you
can see that very quickly without having
to know what the numbers are and then
you could read off the body okay we've
already talked before about what happens
when you've got numbers at the very top
and the very bottom starts with an o
outline is very good this data set it
doesn't really have outliers does it
okay I mean you could kind of argue that
these are guys up here sort of like
outliers but it's not like they're
completely far away from the dead body
there's no just a small number which is
we can expect okay so you can see these
things very quickly that's great